the substance of the case you were
making which was that first of all you
had been infected by covid before and so
presumably had natural immunity to the
virus that as far as we knew at the time
was as good or better and that's only
been borne out by the evidence since
I want to just pull up a little bit of
your Wall Street Journal op-ed you said
that uh these coercive mandates violate
basic principles of medical ethics
informed consent is likewise required is
required for medical decisions in all
adults of sound mind this is arguably
the most deeply rooted Doctrine in
contemporary medical ethics
um first could you talk about informed
consent and then I have a follow-up
question about vaccine mandates as a The
Wider the broader concept of vaccine
mandates beyond the covid vaccine yeah
so informed consent in a nutshell is the
notion that adults of sound mind
have the right to accept or decline
proposed medical interventions after
receiving adequate information about the
risks benefits and alternatives to those
treatments and they have the right to
make those decisions on behalf of their
children who are too young to consent
um and even in people who are
incapacitated and can't give consent
because they're in a coma we still have
to obtain informed consent for medical
interventions from a proxy from a family
member or from someone who's been
appointed a conservator or power of
attorney
and this Doctrine goes all the way back
to the early 20th century but that one
of the landmark articulations was of
course the Nuremberg code following the
Nazi doctor trial where about a dozen a
couple of dozen uh Nazi Physicians were
tried for crimes against humanity for
basically doing gruesome experiments on
death camp prisoners without those
prisoners consent and the world
responded with horror some of those
doctors actually received the death
penalty and hung about half half dozen
of them were convicted uh
for capital crimes
and the nurburg code grew out of the
experience of the Nuremberg trials in
the very first principle articulated in
the Nuremberg code is the principle of
informed consent for medical research
which was later applied in federal law
to also requiring informed consent for
all medical interventions and even for
medical tests speaking of speaking of
testing we can't run tests on patients
in most circumstances without gaining
their informed consent
would there ever be a situation where
a vaccine mandate would not violate
medical ethics in in this kind of
emergency type of situ where there's a
panda let's say a deadlier pandemic a
more effective vaccine
um how do you how do those factors
change the calculation if at all from an
ethical Viewpoint so in my view they
don't so I I am an opponent in principle
of vaccine mandates across the board I
think prior to the pandemic I might have
been more open to some of these they're
they're usually theoretical hypothetical
really deadly virus everyone is at risk
which already is not a real world
scenario because really deadly viruses
tend to burn out very quickly they tend
not to produce epidemics or pandemics
because they kill people too quickly
before they can spread so viruses come
in two flavors low mortality viruses
that are very contagious and can spread
across countries or across the
so um so examples of much higher
mortality viruses that um that burn out
rather quickly uh the Ebola virus would
be a good example of that right much
more concerning infection fatality rates
than covet but only
very time limited localized outbreaks
that can be usually be contained much
more easily than something like covid
which is basically impossible to stop
it's okay so where where does something
like uh smallpox work so yeah small
smallpox would be somewhere in the
middle smallpox is probably the
strongest example for vaccine mandates
would be smallpox it's got about a 30
mortality rate so it can produce
epidemics but not not necessarily
pandemics but it certainly can produce
Regional problems
um
the uh
the argument I think when it comes to
something like smallpox even then it
falls apart because if you have
if you have a virus that's deadly enough
and you have an intervention that is
sufficiently effective you have a
sterilizing vaccine that protects the
recipient
um you're not going to have to mandate
it to people people will voluntarily
take it if it's clearly and obviously
good for their health and those that
don't
um are not necessarily putting other
people In Harm's Way because if if if
the intervention is as effective as this
you know hypothetical scenario describes
then the people who want that protection
can have it available to them in the
form of the vaccine so there's a natural
rebuttal to that so frequently I think
about this in the context of smallpox
but also polio because actually when my
son was an infant prior to being
eligible to getting vaccinated against
polio we live right next to
um Hasidic South Williamsburg and so
this was actually kind of an interesting
thing because we had a few cases of
polio detected in New York City and
detected in Rockland County right around
the time when I had a baby in my arms
who had not yet been vaccinated against
polio what do you say in terms of the
you know what do you say to the
immunocompromised or people with really
really small infants were even if they
want to opt into that uh protection
there for whatever reason unable to do
so at that time I'm sure you've
considered this a great length yeah
absolutely
um
so I think bodily integrity and bodily
autonomy are sufficient overriding Goods
um that uh
that accepting some degree of risk in
order to maintain bodily integrity and
bodily autonomy in order to avoid abuses
of power
um is important for us as a society as
as a whole I don't think we want to live
in a society where anyone has the right
to force another person to inject
something into their body that they may
or may not want
um and you know there may be
circumstances where the time limited use
of force to quarantine contagious people
that are symptomatic might be warranted
because that's a that's a Time limited
infringe infringement on civil liberties
that may be justified for the sake of
protecting other people
um but the kind of scenario that you
describe
um we're still talking about
infinitesimally low risks of acquiring a
disease like polio in the in the current
context
um and so I just don't think that that
very small theoretical risk justifies
um forcing vaccines on the Hasidic
Jewish Community for example
yeah I also say that one you know
consequentialist argument of all this
like just have having seen it all play
out is the way that these heavy-handed
mandates were implemented which I was
against from the beginning as well is
that uh predictably people don't like it
and now they're more distrustful of
vaccines on the whole and I think that's
right that's put us in a very dangerous
situation especially given that they now
learned about all this laboratory
manipulation of viruses like who know
what's who knows what's coming and this
is unfortunately an issue like a very
real issue that we have to all think
about both on a policy level and also a
personal level like what we're going to
do if that God forbid what happened I
think to your point Zach there is this
interesting unintended consequence that
all three of us seem to be storing in
the very front of our minds but that for
whatever reason our policy makers uh
haven't really stopped to consider which
is that you do squander public trust and
you might in fact find yourself in a
situation many years down the road where
you wish you hadn't done that I actually
think that to your point Aaron um with
the specific Hasidic example and these
relatively few polio cases that were
detected in the Wastewater in New York
City uh in New York City and surrounding
areas we did actually see in Rockland
County where there's a really really big
Hasidic Enclave exactly what you were
talking about earlier which was a
voluntary vaccination Drive where a
bunch of Hasidic moms seeing the news
about this polio outbreak were like oh
crap a bunch of my kids aren't
vaccinated and just immediately hopped
into action and went to these local
vaccine drives and very quickly got
their children vaccinated recognizing
that up until this point polio isn't
really something that circulates in the
U.S and hadn't really been a realistic
fear but now that there are a few cases
that have been detected now they're
choosing to protect their families and
no government coercion was necessary in
order to get that outcome in fact all
the government did in this case was say
this is available to you here's the news
as to the Wastewater detection here are
the news as to where this is circulating
and if you would like to you can come to
this place and get this free vaccine
available to you and people decided to
opt into that of their own volition
which I think is a really heartening
case study
but that is a beautiful real world
example of
good Public Health functioning well and
and relying on the Goodwill
uh and the trust and the Civic
mindedness and the other directedness of
you know most Americans
including people that might you know
naturally because of cultural or
religious reasons have skepticism about
the need for those things and you know
we don't have to coerce parents to help
their kids brush their teeth right or to
feed their kids or to you know
um
take them outside once in a while so
they get sunlight because most parents
want to do the best thing for their
children and their children's health
when you start forcing things on them
going back to the discussion of masks or
you mandate a vaccine for an illness
that they're they're not at high risk
from and That vaccine has potential side
effects or adverse consequences you
squander precisely that trust in that
Civic mindedness of uh voluntary
voluntarily complying in situations in a
sort of other directed community-minded
Spirit and I think that is a per the
situation you described is a perfect
contrast to what we actually did in
covid and you see you see the different
results and you see the different
attitudes that both of those things
fostered in the community and I think it
becomes pretty clear that you know we
can we can come up with hypothetical
scenarios that you know might incline us
to believe yeah we should Force this on
people but if you see how that actually
plays out historically in real world
examples I think it becomes very clear
that that's not the that's not the way
to go with Public Health
thanks for watching that clip from our
conversation with Aaron carriati about
the return of covid mandates and his
book the new abnormal you can watch
another clip from that conversation
right here or the full conversation over
here